Good morning, John.
VidCon day 2.
What am I gonna do in my video today?
Well, I got to talk to a bunch of, uh,
educational YouTube creators recently,
so I decided, hey, you know what?
Everybody thinks these folks are so smart.
What if I ask them a bunch of trivia questions to see how smart they really are?
Turns out,
pretty smart because how many trivia questions you know
the answer to doesn't really impact how smart you are.
But regardless... [laughs] My voice!
Here's the video of a bunch of Youtubers trying to answer some trivia questions
Does this make me smarter?
United Service Bot.
Universal... something...
Hub. Hu-buh.
Ultra Service Burgers, because all b's are now burgers.
United Service Bureau
Utility Saving Button?
Universal Serial Bus
[ding]
Talking about bears like [growls] bears?
Sunshine bear!
A teddy bear?
Black bear. No, Pooh Bear!
(singing) Pooh bear!
Oh polar bears.
Roller bears.
Black bear.
Ursa Major.
The highland sloth bear.
A water bear
That's the correct answer.
Black bear. Yeah, absolutely.
It can thrive whereas every other species of bear has declined.
Oh no...
Lyndon Johnson.
Maybe these aren't making me smarter.
It wasn't Johnson.
I'm gonna go with Gerald Ford and I just don't know... the answer seems to come out of the ether to me.
Gerald Ford.
[ding]
Tibet?
I'm gonna go with Nepal.
Uh... India?
Tibet?
Nepal?
Don't know this.
Is that...isn't it India, right?
I want to say India.
That's why we watch Geography Now.
It is in both Nepal and China.
[ding]
That I'm in or that exists in the world?
There's one where I'm wearing a beanie that I don't think has held up particularly well.
My first video.
This one.
I made a song called Boogers in My Nose.
It's in the style of three six mafia
I make physics videos now, but I still have some long hair tutorials on my channel so...
I made a video called Spider Versus Penis.
It's a good video.
I'm not ashamed of that. It's a good video.
When I made a shake weight into a generator.
Boogers in My Nose...that seems to be the issue.
[ding]
Those little glow worms in the caves.
My ex-boyfriend.
Like a zebra.
[Hank] A zebra?
Yeah.
[Hank] Zebras are not creepy!
Have you ever encountered a zebra at night?
Honey badgers?
Oh, uh like a scorpion?
Scorpions.
Oh, scorpions.
Scorpion.
Scorpions.
It's not scorpion. Maybe a scorpian?
[ding]
Wow
Is it French? Don't know a lot of French.
Cooking good food.
Le Petomane was a horse.
Oh that was um, the move that you do in order to, um,
soothe a dog.
Astronomy?
Sounds like a chemical.
Sounds like it could be a drug name.
That sounds like a drug.
It's the active ingredient in Imodium
[buzzer]
I was so disappointed that nobody knew who Le Petomane was. Come on!
And then after the last person I quizzed, was Kati Morton,
and I was walking out and her husband, Sean, who's amazing,
great friend of mine, was...here it is. I'll show you.
Wait, wait, wait.
Do you know who Le Petomane is? You'd be the only person to get it right?
This is a French man from France who could fart and he was an entertainer
So yay, I can't believe that we forget these amazing things about history
There was a guy who was a professional farter. Anyway, that's all I got. I gotta do VidCon stuff now.
John, I'll see you like right after I go out that door or before actually, maybe.
Come on over!